[Music]
genomics is extending its reach into
diverse fields of biomedical research
from agriculture to clinical diagnostics
despite sharp falls in recent years
sequencing costs remain substantial and
vary for different types of experiment
consequently in all of these fields
investigators are seeking experimental
designs that generate robust scientific
findings for the lowest sequencing cost
higher coverage of sequencing inevitably
requires higher costs
in next generation sequencing studies
the term depth of coverage refers to how
strong is a genome covered by sequenced
fragments or short reads
per base coverage is the average number
of times a base of a genome is sequenced
the coverage depth of a genome is
calculated as the number of bases of all
short reads that match a genome divided
by the length of this genome
it is often expressed as 1x 2x 3x and
etc
breadth of coverage refers to how much
of a genome is covered by short reads
are there regions that are not covered
even not by a single red
breadth of coverage is the percentage of
bases of a reference genome that are
covered with a certain depth
for example here is an example for whole
genome sequencing
what coverage of a human genome will one
get with one lane of a hisec 2000 in
paired end mode
if 200 million clusters were bound
in this case paired in doubles the read
length because each fragment is
sequenced from both sides
the number of sequenced bases can also
be computed by the number of reads x red
length
it should be noted that the computed
average is a theoretical unit
reads are not distributed evenly over an
entire genome
that is an important fact especially for
whole genome sequencing
therefore many bases will be covered by
fewer reads than the average coverage
while other bases will be covered by
much more reads than average
coverage histograms are commonly used to
depict the range
and uniformity of sequencing coverage
for an entire data set
they illustrate the overall coverage
distribution by displaying the number of
reference bases that are covered by
mapped sequencing reads at various
depths
mapped read depth refers to the total
number of bases sequenced and aligned at
a given reference base position
in a sequencing coverage histogram the
read depths are bend and displayed on
the x-axis
while the total numbers of reference
bases that occupy each red depth bin are
displayed on the y-axis
these can also be written as percentages
of reference bases
ideally the plot will take the form of a
poisson-like distribution with a small
standard deviation
as seen in the left-hand histogram image
this distribution is valid under the
assumption that reads are randomly
distributed across the genome
and that the ability to detect true
overlaps between reads is constant
within a sequencing run
however for a variety of reasons actual
coverage histograms may have a large
spread
or have a nonpoisson distribution as
seen in the right hand example of a poor
sequencing coverage histogram
to evaluate the quality of the ngs
coverage
three common metrics are usually used
interquartile range or iqr
the iqr is the difference in sequencing
coverage between the 75th
and 25th percentiles of the histogram
this value is a measure of statistical
variability
reflecting the non-uniformity of
coverage across the entire data set
a high iqr indicates high variation in
coverage across the genome
while a low iqr reflects more uniform
sequence coverage
in the example histograms here the lower
iqr indicates that the histogram on the
left has better sequencing coverage
uniformity than that on the right
mean read depth the mean red depth or
mean mapped red depth
is the sum of the mapped read depths at
each reference base position
divided by the number of known bases in
the reference
the mean red depth metric indicates how
many reads on
average are likely to be aligned at a
given reference based position
raw read depth this is the total amount
of sequence data produced by the
instrument during pre-alignment
divided by the reference genome size
although raw red depth is often provided
by sequencing instrument vendors as a
specification
it does not take into account the
efficiency of the alignment process
if a large fraction of the raw
sequencing reads are discarded during
the alignment process
the post alignment mapped red depth can
be significantly smaller than the raw
red depth
an ideal genome sequencing method would
faultlessly read all nucleotides just
once
doing so sequentially from one end of a
chromosome to the other
such a perfect approach would ensure
that all polymorphic alleles within
diploid or polyploid genomes could be
identified
and that long identical or near
identical repetitive regions could be
unambiguously placed in a genome
assembly
in real world sequencing approaches read
lengths are short
often less than or equal to 250
nucleotides and can contain
sequence errors when considered alone an
error is indistinguishable from a
sequence variant
this problem can be overcome by
increasing the number of sequencing
reads
even if reads contain a one percent
variant error rate
the combination of eight identical reads
that cover the location of the variant
will produce a strongly supported
variant call with an associated error
rate of 10 power of -16
increased depth of coverage therefore
rescues inadequacies in sequencing
methods
nevertheless generating greater depth of
short reads does not cure all sequencing
ills
in particular it alone cannot resolve
assembly gaps
that are caused by repetitive regions
with lengths that either approach
or exceed those of the reeds